it's time for roses and roses a hi
everybody these are not diff I wear hash
tag not an A - tag not sponsored you
guys it was the finale of bachelor in
paradise it's been a week of change so
we're gonna have to take a pause on
roasts and rose' and mourn Peter is not
our bachelor everyone Peter is not our
bachelor if you watch this show how much
I wanted but it's okay because we want
Peter to be happy and because Ari is a
35 year old dude who is gonna bring us
hopefully some mature stuff and not some
social media relationships and so I'm
onboard Ferrari because I am on board
with this franchise and I support it
till the end but a good thing I have
secured the first on-camera interview
with Peter crap it's gonna be up on TV
online today it's today back to our
regularly scheduled programming
everybody and what am I gonna do with
four hours out of my week every week now
a lot of stuff so bachelor in paradise
is over and let's be honest I love the
show the finale was a little bit of a
letdown I've got my rose' in a coffee
cup today cuz I got to wake up after all
that last dime right
this has been a wild ride from start to
finish we had the shutdown there was a
time when we thought that paradise
wasn't going to happen
Chris Harrison is like it's the last day
in paradise guys and it's been a wild
ride I'll agree with that to a certain
extent and a lot of weird crap happened
I don't know how wild the whole ride was
but now people are gonna like decide I
guess if their couples are not I don't
remember the formula of the show and
let's be honest they've thrown all the
roles out this season
and created some new ones so I don't
know I think people have to pick like
are we together and then if not they
leave my bar Kristin for a minute Jack
pulls Kristin aside and was a gem of the
moment drink every time things were so
insanely awkward that you wanted to get
up and go get a snack
aka more wine from the other room so you
didn't have to watch this conversation I
want to get off this beach already and
see what happens you know like okay okay
wait wait so Kristin's like we're
friends we are
acquaintances right now your heart says
couple right now mine says friends right
now I'm freaking out a little bit whoa
that was weird I wouldn't go so far as
to say there you're just a queen this is
Kristen I mean you guys made out like a
lot but anyway then I guess Jack leaves
so if you're not a couple than you leave
it's very hunger dance scouting yourself
Kristen goes swimming alone into the
ocean probably because the producer told
her to and everyone at the bar is like
then tickle monster and Jasmine very
amicably an adult elite agree to part
ways I didn't know they were together
drink every time a couple breaks up when
you didn't really know they were
together Taylor can I steal my fiance
please
Adam called Raven his fiancee whoa Adam
I've met Adam a couple times now and I
interviewed Adam and Raven in Stephanie
online comments super cute back to the
awkward Dean and Danielle we thought
that Dean had done all he could to make
us want to scream so loudly and
consistently in his face over and over
again
Oh Dean Dean sit no quick summary Dean
picked Danielle and Christina left
paradise you and I obviously kind of
started off on a weird foot because
Christine Oh is here right yeah now Dean
is sitting with Danielle and sing I kind
of realized that I care a lot about
Christina
and that's I I love her and that I think
I owe it to her for us to walk away from
this separately so oh my god drink every
time Dean again makes you want to just
and crush something small in your hand
in his crush it Tina's like a little
confused boy didn't I interviewed him
last week about the whole Dean Christina
Danielle situation and that's up aditi
online comm spyler alert he hates the
term I wonder why please sensor that JC
I have to give Danielle a kg load so
much credit here because girl maintains
her composure she just threw him some
side-eye
for days they're still having feelings
for her and I think he need to figure
things out for yourself yes Queen yes
yes yes this finale was about if nothing
else the women slaying the situations
yes
not necessarily in what was taped in
Mexico but wait till we get to the cast
reunion mmm second half of yep
to kill me yeah and then Dean's like if
I hadn't picked in yo think we would be
here right now talking about Christian
and me instead of Dan yelling me right
that's just simple math and logic Dean
and you need to follow those principles
more okay okay if you like a girl tell
her you like her don't say I like the
other girl anyway I'm hoping that he
does see the same potential that I see
he does see potential for a future
biggie and Dominique
Dominique's Dominique's into Diggy and
then he breaks up with her and then
Diggy and Jamie is that her name and
Dickies into Jamie and Jamie breaks up
with him and everybody goes home alone
patience is a virtue slow as steady wins
the race
Robbie and Amanda have been very tight
almost all season and now they're gonna
decide you know are they gonna go to
like a fantasy suite or whatever
together and Robbie again is like I am
so into Amanda things are so real and
then Amanda is like no no no what girl
is breaking down in tears time Robbie
it's not gonna work it's very unclear
why but what is clear is that I hate
watching Amanda Stanton cry she is
beautiful she is like a fairy princess
and I can not handle those tears and do
I hate watching Robbie cry it was hard
to tell
[Music]
was he crying or was he just sort of
like see it looked kind of like I was
crying there you know so I leave a poll
in the comments below do you think
Robbie was really crying tough call and
things are gonna get tougher in the
reunion you'll see what happens
Robbie I'm terrified
just how Daniel then I'm in love with
him Lacy and Daniel who thought we would
be talking about them so much on the
finale no one would think that would
happen
right right so Lacey is really into
Daniel oh she's like I'm falling for you
and Daniel says the same and he keeps
bringing up changing his facebook status
which makes me think Daniel is like like
why are you so obsessed with your
facebook status Derek and Taylor are in
the fantasy suite and I've got a call
Taylor out for a minute here because she
said something that several people said
this episode which was driving me crazy
she said I could possibly be moving in
the direction of falling in love with
him I could possibly see myself maybe
falling in love with him
first of all you two are together okay
and second of all I could possibly cut
out one of the words everybody stop
filling up these four hours with
unnecessary words Corinne so now we're
to the reunion part of things and it's
Karenin Demario meeting for the first
time since the scandal and they don't
say very much we do know that Corinne is
working on a fashion line therapy has
been really good for me - you're gonna
have so much spotlight you've had so
much spotlight anyway
also never buddy catch Christina's face
when Corinne said
[Music]
and Peter's not the best of my party B
right now if you were saying that you
were in love with Christina this whole
time that you love her like and we left
the show immediately after like within
an hour you called me why did you call
me when the camera stopped rolling and
we hung out Oh winter is coming
yeah it's here and actually we hung out
like the weekend after paradise she like
asked me to be his girlfriend Amanda
says her and Robbie actually got back
together after paradise but then ever
since broken up after she gave him quote
20 direct quote 20 chances maybe 20
chances damn damn and Robbie gotta come
out after this and booboo was backstage
and did not know about any of this
conversation so Robbie sits down to play
the social-media influencer politician
of relationships there's certain wants
needs and expectations that you need
from your counterpart I mean like Chris
we broke up because you know people are
different communication is difficult
people have different priorities and
relationships but she's too nice but I
don't know he's just not ready for a
relationship I mean just the rumors that
he did cheat on Amanda the twins have
their girls back
back from a commercial break and things
get even more WTF Daniel comes out and
we find out that Daniel told lacy that
when he said I love you and I want to be
in a relationship with you he was joking
I'm sorry as finger says what what a
sphincter says what he says he was
joking or lying or something and he
talks about facebook statuses again
right like I could never change my
facebook status to relationship of a
[Music]
footage not that footage Adam and Raven
we're still showing the fantasy suites I
guess we still footage of that I don't
know again the formula I'm confused but
anyway Adam and Raven are together and
Adam meets her parents and they're
really cute but then Derek and Taylor
come out looking like George and Amal
Clooney they look so good and Derek you
make me the happiest man on this planet
will you marry me you know it was a
lovely moment and I'll take it after
this summer of scandal and shutdown and
exhaustion time I'm tired I'm tired
everyone everyone's tired we're all
tired it's just been it's been too much
you know it's been too much it's been
four hours a week I'm exhausted
I am tired I am deflated okay bachelor
in paradise took it all out of me
okay I'm trying I'm trying to read in
and I'm trying to open a new chapter and
reinvigorate myself
but nothing is happening I'm exhausted
I'm ready for the bachelor you guys
paradise has been four hours a week
every week after all this is letdown the
scandal Stefan anxious
is it paradise anymore is it or is it a
dark and sad place that we've got to
crawl our way out of like crabs in the
sand I wrote a little song about it as a
way through the waters of Playa
Escondido take a look at my TV and say
whoa it's for Neto
I've been obsessed with the scandal too
long even the crabs are wondering hey
what went wrong we've been spray ons and
most our lives watching fall I was the
weaker paradise we've been spending most
our lives watching for hours a week of
paradise and tell me why are we so into
b.a.p when the sea then ended with
Daniel and Laci seriously you guys thank
you so much for watching this is very
lengthy season of bachelor in paradise
with me I love the show you love the
show I love you please make sure to LIKE
ET on Facebook subscribe to us on
YouTube you can talk about everything
bachelor with me over on social media
and I will give you all the latest and
greatest some greatest and brightest
greatest play this is brightest and
greatest bachelor news thank you I love
you we'll be back
roses and rose a these are not defy
where everybody hashtag not an ad
hashtag not sponsored is that camera
right is that way
[Laughter]